SOCHIL MARTIN: We need
to do something about it.
It's dangerous for us now.
SPEAKER: There are chunks
of my childhood.
Black holes, black spaces.
I asked her,
"How far back does this go?"
And she said,
"It goes all the way back."
♪ (SOMBER MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
MARTIN: La Luz del Mundo
is a church founded in 1926.
Anywhere, you name it,
there's a Church of
The Light of the World.
La Luz del Mundo claims to have
five million members
in 57 countries.
One of the largest
religious cults of our time.
MARTIN: In addition to
the yachts and the cars,
they have ranches
in Texas and California.
The church has one leader
at a time.
And that's the apostle.
There have been three apostles
in the same family.
With three generations of abuse
that have been covered up
till now.
I wanted to prove
that I was worthy.
MARTIN: They almost
make it seem romantic.
Like a fairytale.
You're gonna be a princess.
He hit me until I fell.
SPEAKER 2:
SPEAKER 3:
You might think it's a sin,
but it's not because it's
in the presence of the apostle.
They cut ties with your family.
My mother,
she doesn't talk to me.
(SPEAKING SPANISH)
SPEAKER 4:
SPEAKER 3: The reason why
I want to remain anonymous
is the fear.
MARTIN: If something happens
to me, my daughter,
or my husband,
it's coming from them.
This isn't a church.
This is some sort of mafia.
SPEAKER 5: The first thing
we think is exposure.
We gotta expose it.
MARTIN: I started to reach out
to people in the United States.
Everybody in the MeToo movement.
Never got anything back
from anybody.
SPEAKER 5: The Bible says,
"Maintain justice
and do what is right."
This has to stop.
I think that
this would have been different
if these were
white, American girls.
We need to get justice.
MARTIN: They have so much power.
SPEAKER 5: It got bigger.
Everybody exposing this beast.
SPEAKER 6: (SPEAKING SPANISH)
The truth is there.
(SPEAKING SPANISH)
I forgive myself.
It was never a blessing.
I want to be a voice
for all the other little girls.